the Dodger pitcher rich Hill last night
a pretty remarkable game had a perfect
game going into the ninth no-hitter
going into the 10th and ended up losing
it on a walk-off home run how do you
feel today rich you know tough loss last
night but you know body feels body feels
pretty good today so just get back to
work
was there any talk of you not going out
for the 10th inning no not for the 10th
but possibly the 11th you know you know
if we we got through the temps but
unfortunately made you know one pitch
and ran over the middle and you know
Harrison did what he was supposed to do
with it and it without a ballpark so it
feels like we're more bothered by you
losing the no-hitter than you are well
you put in the I always say this you
know you put in the days the weeks a
month the years and in some cases the
decades of you know getting to a certain
point and something that's happening
here is extremely special so you know
with the season with the team and you
know what our end goal ultimately we
have our sights on is where we want to
go so individual accomplishments and
certain things are great but it really
at the end of the day you know will will
fall in comparison to what what the main
goal is here ever had that feeling that
you had through the first nine innings
in a game last year I think in Miami you
know after seven you know with the
perfect game and then this year
obviously last night but yeah I think
that that was really the first time you
know in my career being that close to
something like that but you know again
one bad pitch and we end up losing the
game so that's really know it's a little
little mundane but really at the end of
the day the the you know the main main
objective is to go out there and get a W
win
when did you know you were in trouble on
that pitch
you know yes probably it happened so
quick I you know and as soon as the ball
was in the air I could tell off that but
it had it had a chance to get out it
wasn't obviously a no-doubter but you
know I could tell in the air that it had
out of camp would you rather have two
no-hitters or one perfect game let's say
you had a World Series title but we were
talking about this I said there's only
been 23 perfect games in baseball
history and there's been right you know
250 no-hitters so right I got a nice one
perfect then - no no no right yeah that
that would be I think that would be my
answer as well so if I if you had that
if I had to make a you know you're
forcing me to make make a decision here
and say I need an answer I would say the
perfect game what was the locker room
like last night I know it was a loss so
you know quiet and you know I I don't
think anybody really knows how to react
in a situation like that this is very
rare and doesn't happen very often right
but looking forward to today and taking
mysterious from Pittsburgh I think it's
something that you know you know it's
quiet but it's like when somebody loses
a family member you never know what to
say to the family member this is like
baseball's equivalent and losing a
family member
[Music]
react in their own way and I think in
that situation it's something that you
know is understandable and and I know
everybody out you know everybody gave an
incredible effort last night and that
was really something that you could see
I'm something that you know when
handsome owner you watch us on TV the
Dodgers on TV that's what you're going
to see every single night and I don't
know if you've been able to catch any of
the games but you know it's a resilient
the inanimate continuous pressure that
we put on the other teams that has made
us an extremely good team this year I'm
talking to rich Hill the Dodgers pitcher
took a no-hitter into the 10th a shutout
and lost that on a Joshua Harrison with
the walk-off home run but I wonder if
here you are 37 that everything else
prepares you for hey I can't be any more
disappointed than I was with what
happened there was a stretch where you
weren't even pitching in the major
leagues how how did the previous part of
your career help you in dealing with
whatever comes up in your career now
well that's experienced and I think you
can draw from your experiences throw a
wife and as you get older you know and
you can look back and and kind of as
they say connect the dots looking
backwards instead of you know moving
forward but again it's just uh it's
really continuing to put the the effort
in and I always and I always say that
it's about you know putting the effort
in at the end of the day and going out
there and giving everything that you
have out of the mound
and I know you know athletes say that
over and over again but really to
believe that and to understand what that
means as I've gotten older is what I can
draw from through experiences you know
something like last night is you know a
very small thing compared to what we all
I mean what I've gone through in life
and you know and and moving forward and
understanding that putting yourself out
there and actually taking action and
giving everything that you have is going
to fall more often than not in your
favor if you continue to put that put
that forward what if you ran across Josh
Harrison today prior to the game what
would you say no I congratulate him you
know I mean he did do what he's supposed
to do you know the ball that cut back
over the middle of the plate and he put
a great wing on it so i apprec--
going on
for example Clayton Kershaw and what
he's been able to do in his career and
no Cody Bellinger Adrian Gonzalez mm hit
the other night
Chase Utley you know how it you know
he's had a tremendous career
what Kenley Jansen has been able to do
you know this year and Alex wood just
watching these guys and Chris Taylor I
mean you know nobody really had
mentioned Chris Taylor at all and now
he's he's you know kind of a household
name I guess you want to say that just
because of the way he's been able to
adjust and continue to grind throughout
his career and that those are the things
that are special because you see that
and you don't know when it's going to
come around again and I think that is
what I can draw from my experiences as
well seeing you know great milestones
for individuals throughout their career
and really appreciating that and you see
that and you say wow that's pretty
special who's the funniest guy on the
team yeah definitely give me an example
I don't know he has you know really good
width dry humor this the way he can keep
the bench loose in any situation whether
we're up or down or you know uh no
hitter or perfect hands on on just just
to go or whether you know for example if
the games not going well for certain
guys you know he can he can always have
something to say that will make you
laugh so it's it's uh it's something
that it's unique and then and and pretty
special so did guys not talk to you in
the dugout
last night when did they stop talking to
you last night yeah I kind of I'm kind
of a pacer during the game so I tend us
not to sit down in one spot so I didn't
really get the you know team on one side
of the dugout and you know a picture of
the other half of the dough so you
them out you you you stayed away from
them it doesn't matter if was what was
going on last night or was no any other
game I tend to I tend to move around a
lot but I'd say I would say around the
seventh inning yeah well congratulations
whatever you take out of it it was it
was great TV i I got a heads up to tune
in and the night first pitch I saw the
error by foresight and then you retired
the next three and I go okay
is he coming out for the tenth and then
when you did and I went oh yeah yeah
thank you I really appreciate it and
congratulations to yourself with
everything you know in your career thank
you rich I appreciate it and good luck
with the rest of the season
okay that's rich Hill the Dan Patrick
show weekday mornings on audience